bonsoir et bienvenue pour cette nouvelle
édition du Journal de la rédaction sur
TV fil 78 il est 18h si vous nous suivez
en direct et voici les titres de ce
lundi 27 octobre les pratiques de pêche
des bateaux qui fournissent la société
petit Navi sont dans le collimateur de
Greenpeace une campagne nationale se
déroule en ce moment pour sensibiliser
les cons ateur opération coup de point
des militants samedi matin dans une
grande surface de 50 ans en Yveline des
militants et qui seront en plateau ce
soir les 21 hectares du site boa Louis
Michel sur la commune de trappe doivent
faire l'objet d'aménagement et de
développement pour renforcer leur
insertion urbaine c'est un projet
développé dans le cadre de l'opération
d'intérêt national Paris saclé nous en
parlerons avec Jean-Marie Le Maire lu
directeur adjoint de l'aménagement de
l'établissement public Halloween ce sera
le 31 octobre mais déjà sorcières et
monstres envahissent le parc de Toir
petit PES et grands qui jouent à se
faire peur tout au long de la semaine
les ivelinois du Front national se sont
rassemblés ce lundi matin sur le parking
de l'usine PSA à poissie suite à
l'annonce de la direction du groupe de
supprimer 98 postes sur ce site les
militants FN ont souhaité aller à la
rencontre des travailleurs pour leur
exposer leurs idées et lutter contre les
délocalisations je pense notamment à la
remise de
frontière et mettre des règles également
pour pour réguler un système devenu fou
une mondialisation devenue folle mettre
en là c'est un protectionnisme
économique et cette usine un peu un peu
déserte c'est le le symbole de cette
désindustrialisation complète de notre
nation et ça on le on le supporte plus
beaucoup de gens ont nos idées mais mais
ils fantasment sur sur notre parti en
pensant qu'on a il y en a même encore
qui pensent qu'on est limite raciste
nazi ou autre et évidemment qu'on est
loin de ça et et c'est pour ça qu'il
faut aller à la rencontre des gens leur
expliquer nos idées leur expliquer notre
programme et pour qu'il cesse de croire
tout ce qui peut être peut être énoncé
dans les médias ou par nos opposants peu
de monde cependant vous l'avez vu sur
les images au passage des porties ce
midi les travailleurs de l'usine sont en
effet en ce moment au chômage technique
ils ont été enenvoyés à leur domicile
pour 4 jours les militants du Front
national qui ont donc prévu de réitérer
cette opération je reçois pour débuter
ce journal Anou voisin et Thierry Daras
bonjour à tous les deux et bienvenue
Greenpeace vous êtes des militants
Greenpeace qui dénonce certains
dispositifs de pêche utilisés notamment
par la société petit navire vous avez
mené une opération au coup de point dans
une grande surface de ce weekend on va y
venir mais tout d'abord quoi consiste
cette technique de pêche utilisée donc
par cette société que vous contestez
aujourd'hui qu'est-ce qui vous gêne dans
la technique de pêche
utilisée B en fait c'est une technique
de pêche qui va le principe en fait
c'est on va y avoir un ob un objet
flottant et comme en en mer ça va être
considéré comme un habitat pour pour des
petits poissons des petites espèces qui
vont par là du coup attirer les gros
poissons et donc va y avoir tout un un
écosystème qui va se créer autour de ces
objets flottants et après les pêcheurs
vont donc c'est c'est eux même qui
mettre ces objets plottants pour créer
cet écosystème et attirer donc les les
Grot tons mais également les juvéniles
hein tout est présent c'est vraiment un
écosystème développé et donc ils
arrivent avec les les des gros filets
pour attraper le tout et donc c'est une
une méthode qui n'est pas du tout
sélective donc on va avoir un taux de
rejet qui est deux fois quatre fois plus
élevé que sans cette méthode de DCP donc
dispositif de TR des poissons qui ne
souhaitaent pas forcément avoir mais
comme il rafle tout partout et il
remettent ensite à l'eau une partie VO
il pêche une partie des poissons donc
des requins des RS don des tortues donc
des espèces en danger qui vont rejeter
espèces protégé voilà mortes ou en
mourante et également ce qu'on des
petits des tons donc c'est le but mais
qui sont trop jeunes pour être pêché et
donc qui va empêcher le renouvellement
du stock donc c'est tous ces toutes ces
chosesl qu'on qu'on déonce mais c'est la
société petit navire que vous ciblez en
particulier c'est la seule société
utiliser cette méthode de de pêche non
il y a plusieurs sociétés en fait on a
on a établi un classement de 10 société
qui représente 75 % du du marché et bon
petit navire est important parce qu'il
représente en fait une boîte de temps
sur deux acheté par les Français donc
c'est une cible préférée mais il n'y a
pas que il n'y a pas que vous avez donc
mené une action ce weekend dans les
Yveline dans une des grandes surfaces du
département voici le reportage de
clairire Cambier B fais la même longueur
al ces militants de Greenpeace se
préparent à une opération commando le
but d'énoncer les pratiques de pêche non
durable avec dans leur viseur la marque
Petit Navire en tête samedi ils se sont
introduits dans le magasin Carrefour de
Saint-Quentin en Yveline sur ces images
filmé par Greenpeace on voit les
militants dévoiler leur appartenance à
l'ONG environnementale retirer les
boîtes de thon de la marque incriminé et
afficher une banderolle petit navire le
bon goût du carnage la sécurité du
magasin est intervenue mais leur message
a pu être délivré donc elle pêche des
tonges qui sont soit en voie de
disparition soit sont sur le point de
l'être et d'utr d'autre part ces
méthodes de pêche utilisant des DCP les
DCP sont des dispositifs de
concentration de poisson qui sont
repérés par
GPS font que des poissons qui ne sont
pas compatibles avec la pêche durable
sont rejetés en mer car ils sont pris
avec les bands de thon ces images sont
diffusées par l'ONG 20 % de la pêche des
tonniers serait rejeté requin tortu ré
bonjour monsieur un petit peu
d'information sur la technique de pêche
de petit navire et les dangers pour les
après avoir échoué à dialoguer avec
Petit Navire l'ONG s'adresse aujourd'hui
aux consommateurs et au distributeurs
ici Carrefour elle espère qu'ils
pousseront le leader du marché à changer
ses pratiques on propose aux gens
d'interpeller bah petit navire pour leur
demander de changer leur politique de
pêche ben régulièrement effectivement
Greenpeace a mené des opérations de ce
type simultanément dans près de 25
villes
françaises voilà pour voilà pour cette
opération menée par Greenpeace sur
SaintQuentin en Eveline ce weekend
comment on réagit et l'enseigne et la
marque Petit Navire après cette
opération la marque on sait pas trop fa
si on sait pour l'instant elle veut pas
réagir elle veut pas s'engager alors que
il y a certaines marques qui qui font
partie du même groupe en Angleterre en
Italie qui se sont engagé d'ici 2016 à
avoir 100 % de leurs tons qui sont pas
de qui ne proviennent pas de DCP euh
petit navir pour l'instant ne souhait
pas s'engager mais bon on espère que
dans les semaines à venir avec la
pression qu'on va continuer à à à
apporter ils vont ils vont et les
clients que vous avez interpellé parce
que le but c'était aussi d'inpeller les
consommateurs ils réagissent comment ils
sont au courant ils s'en moquent ils
vont faire attention à ce qu'il consomme
on a été très très bien reçu la majorité
des clients je dirais nous a bien
accueilli était très compréhensif euh
ils comprennent ils ont en tête la
problématique du ton rouge qui est pas
tout à fait la même mais mais on a été
très très bien reçu on a signé pas mal
de pétitions et on pensait que ça peut
faire changer l'achat le consommateur va
acheter différemment va faire plus
attentionoui oui oui tout à fait c'est
l'objectifier l'objectif c'est de notre
liste aussi c'est de mettre en avant par
exemple p deckmou ou le système qui eux
ont des ont des bonnes notes dans notre
classement c'est-à-dire que ils
utilisent des techniques de pêche qui ne
sont pas aussi destructifes que petit
navire qui est donc vers la fin du
classement alors quelle serait la
solution justement c'est de changer
complètement la méthode quelle méthode
faudrait-il utiliser alors il y a
d'autres méthodes des méthodes de pêche
à la ligne ou de même des des méthodes
qui utilisent le même type de filet peu
les scèes mais mais sans DCP c'est c'est
réellement la la le l'introduction des
DCP qui pose problème ce sont ces objets
flottants en fait qui attirent les
poissons et ça et ça suffirait
d'utiliser par exemple la pêche à la
canne enfin quelque chose de plus
traditionnel ça ça suffirait à répondre
à la demande actuellement il faut aussi
que le consommateur revoie sa
consommation tout simplement de ton
alors ça suffirait oui parce que il y a
il y a des marques qui pêchent
aujourd'hui systamu par exemple ou
autres d'autres marques pêche avec des
avec des méthodes
durables ensuite on recommande bien
évidemment aux gens de limiter leur
consommation et surtout de consommer des
espèces durables pêcher de façon durable
mais c'est surtout que mieux de suffir
c'est que ça permettrait le long terme
la consommation du temp parce que si on
continue avec ces méthodes de CCP ben on
en aura plus dans quelques années donc
de toute façon autant que ça suffise
aujourd'hui et que ça soit durable là
l'opération a été lancée en septembre au
niveau national donc il y a plusieurs
magasins qui ont été comme ça le théâtre
de de vos opérations est-ce que d'autres
opérations sont prévues est-ce que
d'autres moyens de communication sont
sont déjà d'ors et déjà prévu ou pas il
y aura d'autres moyens de communication
c'est sûr tant que tant qu'on aura pas
un engagement
ferme oui sur d'autres pratiques nous
continuerons après d'autres on peut pas
dire ce qui se passera vous n'z pas
donner à l'avance les prochain
rendez-vous dans les magasins mais en
tout cas vous restez mobilisé c'est ça
le message merci à vous deux greenpce
qui est donc mobilisé contre ces
techniques de pêche pour le ton utilisé
par certaines sociétés mobilisation vous
l'avez entendu qui a débuté le mois
dernier à travers toute la France et qui
va donc se poursuivre justice préson et
l'ouverture à versaill du procès ce
matin d'un ancien policier de 40 ans
accusé d'avoir violé une femme placée en
cellule de dégrisement à montelajolie en
2012 l'homme a bien reconnu un rapport
sexuel mais il aurait été consenti il
ajoute regretter son geste qui a jeté le
discrédit sur sa profession la victime
présente au tribunal maintient ses
accusations elle est jugée comme une
personne fragile mais crédible l'ancien
policier père de famille en cours 20 ans
de réclusion verdict attendu cette
semaine mercredi justice toujours dans
le cadre de leurs études les étudiants
en droit de l'Université de versaill
Saint-Quentin en yeline revti chaque
année revisite pardon chaque année de
grands procès de l'histoire cette année
reconstitution de l'affaire Kennedy
William l et yolen
Tor à Versailles les étudiants
revisitent l'histoire tous les ans
l'association juris tribune reconstitue
un procès historique au tribunal et
cette année l'affaire Kennedy a retenu
leur attention ici pas question de
rejouer le procès à l'identique c'est
une nouvelle enquête qui commence
je'ppelle je signé le 17 mars 19 ça de
savoir si c'est vraiment le métier qu'on
veut ou non et je pense que ça permet
aussi à des étudiants de pouvoir venir
voir avant de se retrouver dans les
Hautes Études dans les masters et cetera
ça permet de voir simplement un procès
le jouris n'a eu que quelques qu'ils
auraiit pu trouver sur internet ou par
eux-même mais on aura rien communiqué et
ils vont tous savoir tout connaître
aujourd'hui et c'est aujourd'hui qu' on
va voir si le procureur Jim Garrison
nouveau du procureur Jim Gon arrive ou
pas à la même finalité qu'au premier
procès à l'époque l'homme d'affaires
clay était accusé de conspiration
d'assassinat mais avait été innocenté à
l'issue du procès aujourd'hui romain
incarne le procureur Jim garison il va
essayer de faire basculer le jugement je
pense que la décision finale va être
différente non pas forcément en fonction
de mon raisonnement mais en fonction du
raisonnement du public et du jury je
vais reprendre la théorie de Jim
Garrison qui est celle du complot
démontrer que c'est pasaroswal qui a tué
Kennedy que c'est une équipe de de
criminel qui a fait ça sous la tutelle
de de clécho et et d'aller dans cette
dynamique là donc c'est discréditer la
le rapport waren et accuser cléchot pour
convaincre les jurés romain a peaufiné
les moindres détails de sa plédoirie
pendant une après-midi les étudiants se
prennent au jeu pour cet exercice
grandeur nature ça leur donne à voir le
droit en acte et non pas seulement
derrière les pupitres de l'université
dans lesqueles ils sont un peu passif
parfois et ce qu' leur apprend aussi la
dialectique du droit c'est-à-dire le
fait que le droit ce n'est pas quelque
chose de monolithique qui qui est dit
excathédra une une vérité révélée mais
qui est quelque chose qu'on qu'on
en fonction des intérêts qu'on doit
défendre et qu'il y a pas une vérité
mais plusieurs vérités qu'on qu'on
essaie de reconstituer sa vérité romain
a réussi à l'imposer 48 ans plus tard
dans ce nouveau procès l'accusé jugé
coupable de complot a écopé d'une peine
de prison à
perpétuité nous allons à présent parler
d'urbanisme du développement de 5 ans en
Eveline dans le cadre du projet Paris
saclclet bonsoir Jean-Marie lerl vous
êtes le directeur adjoint de
l'aménagement public Paris sac 17
octobre dernier en conseil
d'administration vous décidez de la
création d'une zone d'aménagement
concertée une ZAC sur le secteur bobas
Louise Michel à trappe et montinil
Bretonneux l'objectif c'est de faire de
ce site un pôle de développement majeur
à quoi pourrait ressembler ce site à
l'avenir on va en voir des images pour
l'instant c'est plutôt un site à
l'abandon oui c'est un site ferroviaire
qui a fait l'objet d'études de RFF SNCF
qui ont considéré que parmi l'ensemble
des des installations RFF SNCF dans la
région ce site pouvait et devenir autre
chose comme ça rencontre les vœux de de
Monsieur Malandin le maire de trappe il
a été décidé d'en faire un nouveau
quartier un nouveau quartier avec
différentes dimensions à la fois pour y
loger des des habitants à la fois pour y
accueillir des des entreprises mais
aussi des des commerces et des services
en gros jusqu'à présent c'est c'est un
site qui coupe en fait trappe en deux
c'est un corridor ferroviaire est-ce que
ça va garder cette vocation tout de même
tourner vers les transports un peu le
multimodal avec les bus les trains ou al
ce qui est très important c'est c'est ça
tou en effet d'être à 5 10 ou 15 minutes
à pied de deux gares importantes que
celle de trappe et de Montini avec le RC
donc c'est une occasion formidable
d'accueillir une nouvelle population qui
va pouvoir se déplacer en transport en
commun avec le train notamment et et on
pense notamment à à à une génération de
de jeunes actifs qui ne circulent pas
forcément en voiture qui en ont pas
forcément les moyens et en tout cas euh
qui sont obligés d'aller très loin pour
se loger dans des conditions abordables
et donc ce facteur transport va être en
effet très important le but des
aménagements qui sont réalisés par Paris
sacly au-delà de de ce site là c'est
vraiment la mixité pas de zone sans
service c'est c'est le but enseignement
recherche PME grand groupe habitat il
faut réussir à faire cohabiter un petit
peu un petit peu tout le monde oui alors
on est dans on est dans un territoire
déjà très riches euh en en entreprise
euh qui sont parfois un petit peu
cloisonné dans des zones hein d'activité
aujourd'hui on sait que tant pour les
entreprises que pour les logements il
faut aussi des services de proximité des
commerces être dans un cadre urbain
agréable pour pouvoir se se développer
donc il est pas question uniquement de
construire des logements sur ce site il
faut qu'il ait de la vie tout au long de
la journée des services voir des des PME
qui s'y installent exactement c'est ce
qui explique qu'il faut que ce quartier
soit suffisamment significatif
suffisamment important pour que les
commerces puissent vivre puis et pour
faire vivre une superette et quelques
commerces de proximité il faut 400000
habitants au moins pour que ça marche
dans actuellement le site c'est une
vingtaine d'hectares pour qui appartient
pour une grande partie à au réseau feré
de France et à la SNCF comment vous êtes
arrivés sur ce projet justement vous
l'avez mentionné tout à l'heure au début
de l'entretien c'est une volonté aussi
du du maire de la commune guimalandin de
dynamiser un petit peu le secteur de le
réaménager mais comment vous êtes saisi
de ce type de dossier pour
l'établissement public Paris Sacé alors
il y a a il y a une entrée qui est cette
opération d'intérêt national euh pour
laquelle l'établissement public qui a
été créé et qui consiste à faire le le
un cluster mondial dans le domaine de la
recherche technologique et de fabriquer
l'innovation industrielle bon il y a un
certain nombre de de sites de projets
dans notre périmètre dont celui du
couloir ferroviaire et de trappe donc le
maire de traape a en effet considéré que
nous étions légitimes pour intervenir et
l'aider à fabriquer un un nouveau
quartier à l'intérieur de la ville et
lorsqu'on parle de Paris saclé justement
on pourrait penser qu'on parle d'un
territoire assez éloigné non vous
couvrez tout le bassin de Saint-Quentin
en iveline en fait pour être très précis
quel est le secteur un petit peu sur
lequel vous intervenez al
l'établissement public Paris saclé
intervient sur 40 peut intervenir sur 49
communes en gros 45 agglomérations
communauté d'agglomération et dans le
cadre de l'opération d'intérêt national
sur 22 communes qui ont été choisies
très précisément par rapport à leurs
caractéristique physique économique et
et par rapport à la nécessité
d'engendrer dans certains périmètres de
nouveaux projets il y a d'autres projets
qui sont menés actuellement concernant
CTIN en Yveline je pense du côté de
satori par exemple vers le Technocentre
oui alors nous avons pris l'initiative
d'une d'une grande opération
d'aménagement sur le plateau de satori
qui est un espace enseignement militaire
anciennement ou militaire et dans lequel
certaines activités ont déjà démarré
mais il s'agit là aussi de le faire
muter de façon suffisamment importante
et sensible pour créer une nouvelle
dynamique donc n nous allons en effet
est réalisé à partir de satori euh nous
allons contribuer à fabriquer ce pôle
des mobilités du futur qui est l'une des
deux grandes vocation de de Paris sa clé
entre d'une part le le cluster
académique sur le sud du plateau et du
côté des ivelines et notamment en effet
vous citer le Technocentre qui est à
Guill en cours à quelques kilomètres du
plateau de satori ce pôle des mobilité
du futur c'est l'arrivé du nouvelle gare
avec une nouvelle ligne dans le cadre du
Grand Paris voilà exactement le le Grand
Paris qu'on appelle général le métro du
du Grand Paris hein qui va qui va
permettre de relier des des grands
ensembles de la métropole pour faciliter
les le transport la mobilité entre les
les gens qui travaillent et les gens qui
habitent donc c'est dans ce cadre là en
effet que nous allons intervenir pour
bénéficier utiliser les grands
investissements publics puisque c'est 2
milliards et demi quand même
d'investissement sur la ligne 18 euh et
favoriser le le développement des des
activités qui environnent ces nouvelles
gares donc cette ligne 18 he qui passera
à proximité du du du Technocentre sur
sur guillanc c'est le l'un des des
grands projets de Paris saintcay
globalement comment avance le dossier du
Grand Paris le dossier de Paris sa clé
les le développement se fait normalement
malgré les difficultés qui sont
économiques les discussions politiques
parfois qui se lancent qui se relance
oui il y a plusieurs
calendriers le calendrier a commencé par
la création de l'opération
internationale en 2009 la loi de de juin
2010 à d'une part créer le le réseau de
transport ainsi que la possib
possibilité de signer des contrats de
développement territoriaux entre l'État
et les collectivités pour accompagner ce
réseau de transport dans un certain
nombre de projets donc le CDT qui qui
concerne actuellement les deux
agglomérations de versaill- grand parc
et sa-quentin en iveline son projet a
été arrêté il est en phase de
finalisation et sera mis à l'enquête
publique fin décembre voilà pour le
contrat de développement territorial la
ligne 18 en elle-même va faire l'objet
d'une d'une enquête publique aussi dans
dans le courant de de l'année prochaine
et qui va définir les conditions les
emplacements des gares un certain nombre
de caractéristiques pour terminer cet
entretien on va revenir au cœur même de
la raison de votre venue ce soir c'est
cet aménagement sur cette zone
d'activité sur sur trappe quel sera le
le calendrier là on a vu quelques photos
passer tout à l'heure les choses sont
déjà bien avancées il y a déjà des
projets qui sont définis on est au début
du processus hein ce qu'on appelle une
prise d'initiative de Zac elle a deux
volets un volet de commencer à faire les
études les collectivités locales se sont
mises d'accord avec le PPS pour
entreprendre un certain nombre d'études
de faisabilité pré au projet en lui-même
et elle a un volet
concertation qui consiste à bah au fur à
mesure de l'avancement des études tenir
informé la population en débattre
préciser les caractéristiques et aboutir
à un dossier qui sera lui proprement dit
le le dossier de réalisation de Zac
d'ici 1 à 2 ans vous saz que le droit de
l'environnement et droit de l'urbanisme
donne des contraintes maintenant pour
réaliser des morceaux de ville qui sont
très importantes et nécessaire sans
doute pour les questions
environnementales donc d'ici à 2 ans
nous aurons un dossier de réalisation
qui sera approuvé
par les collectivités à nouveau et sur
lequel à partir duquel l'établissement
public va prendre ce qu'on appelle le
risque de l'opération d'aménagement
c'est-à-dire va se lancer dans la
véritable fabrication ce sera financé
comment uniquement par l'établissement
public Paris- sainclay des investisseurs
privés vont vont venir pour réaliser les
les logementsou alors dans un premier
temps nous finançons les études à
travers des cofinancements pour les
études en cours les pps à travers des
subventions d'État à financer la moitié
des études et les collectivités l'autre
moitié dans un deè deè temps lorsque
nous aurons défini le programme détaillé
de l'ensemble de l'opération là nous
nous nous ferons les les travaux nous
acquierrons le le le foncier les terrain
deff cens et cetera et évidemment des
des intervenants privés vont construire
des logement vont construire des des
lieux
d'activité il y a déjà beaucoup
d'engouements est-ce que vous avez été
sollicité par des opérateurs privés déjà
qui sont très intéressé par ce ce
dossier de développement il reste on le
sait finalement région parisienne assez
peu d'endroits où construire donc dès
qu' un endroit se se libère c'est aussi
une solution pour le logement exactement
exactement euh euh évidemment tout
nouveau quartier de cette importance qui
a déjà été d'ailleurs identifié très
récemment à l'occasion d'un comité
interministériel le Premier ministre en
a parlé récemment en ciblant une
vingtaine de projets de cette importance
ou plus ou plus important vont d'une
part recevoir des des comment dire des
des des aides de l'État et d'autre part
commence déjà évidemment à attirer les
investisseurs privés euh avec cette cet
impératif pour nous dans le cadre de
cette opération
d'aménagement qui est d'offrir des
logements
accessiblebl à une population
l'-de-fance qui est obligée de de de
partir de Paris première couronne et
parfois d'aller très loin merci de ces
éclaircissements sur cette futur Zac
donc on en est tout juste au début et
puis plus globalement sur les projets de
de Paris saclet et puis les incidences
sur 50 ans neline Merci à VOUS autre
univers à présent le 31 octobre nous
fêterons Halloween la fête à la mode ces
dernières années le parc de toiri réputé
pour ces animaux a décidé de donner
quelques suur froides à ses visiteurs
cette semaine le reportage réalisé
samedi à la tombée de la nuit par Claire
Cambier et Floran parfait pour Halloween
le château de toiri se transforme en
manoir hanté et le parc en un terrain de
jeu pour monstres en tout genre on est
censé être tous ce soir des fantômes qui
reviennent à la vie le soir d'Halloween
donc on est tous morts dans des
circonstances tragiques donc forcément
on a tous des blessures plus effrayantes
les unes que les autres cinq soirées
pour enfants sont organisées pendant les
vacances scolaires et pour effrayer les
bambins toute l'équipe du parc a été
mise à contribution du soigneur au
responsablebl des ressources humaines
depuis 6 ans ce type d'événement permet
de diversifier l'activité du site c'est
une manière de diversifier et c'est une
manière de visiter Toir aussi autrement
parce que toiri c'est évidemment le parc
animalier qu'on connaît bien mais c'est
aussi des jardins on a de très grands
jardins des espace boisé et un château
petit à petit les enfants arrivent la
gardienne du château uneit Mor qui
connaî tous les recoins du parc les
rejoint il va y avoir des énigmes à
résoudre si vous voulez sortir vivant du
château les enfants vont devoir réussir
chaque épreuve du parcours les indices
obtenus leur permettront d'entrer dans
le château la première étape mais dans
le bain les volontaires ne manquent pas
mais sont vite rattrapés par leur peur
et bien vas-y va nous voir va donc voir
ce qu'il y a dans le
trou y a-t-il quelque chose
que est-ce que tu aperçois quelque chose
oh là
là c'est que le fantôme qui se cache ici
n'est pas très avenant son épreuve
manger des insectes un bon insecte fr
c'est bon pour la croissance la sorcière
mène la troupe d'épreuve en épreuve une
visite atypique du parc animalier mais
qu'est-ce qu'il y a sous les
tombes des
mors vivant le soir
d'Halloween des bruits étrang bois et le
terrible golgote n'est pas loin ce
fantôme muet cherche à retrouver sa
pièce dans ce bocal d'insecte grouillant
après plusieurs tentative la pièce est
retrouvée l'aventure peut continuer
pendant près de 2 Hees le groupe va
rencontrer des personnages effrayants et
même les parents participe une fois
arrivé au château les enfants
déchiffrent les différents indices pour
trouver la formule magique que la
sorcière présente ici don l' si noire
perdre tous ses pouvoirs dans cette VI
dans toutes les eaues ça y est enfin la
voie est libre les enfants peuvent
entrer dans le château et profiter des
friandises en compagnie des fantômes
c'était bien mais ça faisait un petit
peu peur ben j'ai vraiment bien aimé
parce que en France ça se fait pas trop
et je trouvais ça vraiment sympa avec
bah les décors et tout une soirée riche
en émotion pour petits et grands des
soirées pour adultes sont également
proposées depuis 3 ans uniquement pour
les plus téméraires et justement
allez-vous fêter Halloween cette année
c'est notre question du jour
c'était bien qu'on était petit je trouve
pour faire les par visiter les maisons
et touter chercher des bonbons mais
maintenant on est un peu grand peu
passer l'âge mais après une soirée à
thème Halloween c'est vrai que c'estz
sympa non parce que bon déjà c'est une
fête purement commerciale et puis c'est
une fête américaine donc ça n'a pas lieu
d'être en France j'aime bien parce que
je fais à les enfants moi j'aime bien
vraiment je fait Halloween quand j'étais
enfant mais maintenant devenu adulte
c'est plus une fête pour les enfants
quoi moi je pense oui puce que je devais
le faire avec mes amis oui parce que
c'est l'occasion de se retrouver entre
amis et donc je fête Halloween une
soirée organisée entre
étudiants une dernière information pour
clôturer cette édition du 27 octobre le
responsable de la Croix-Rouge à
Saint-Quentin en Eveline décoré Jean-Luc
guisselin a reçu vendredi soir à morpa
l'ordre national du Mérite avec le grade
de chevalier retraité ancien cadre
commercial exerçant à travers l'Europe
il a été distingué pour l'ensemble de
son engagement en présence d'élus locaux
Jean-Luc guisselin est aujourd'hui
président de la délégation locale de la
Croix-Rouge à 50 ans nveline qui couvre
11 communes il gère également deux
épiceries social attrapé à hencour ou
encore un centre d'accueil pour les 100
domicilees fixe à trappe il anime aussi
les formations des bénévoles pour les
tournées de nuit les maraudes il est
enfin membre du Lyon club depuis une
dizaine d'années autant de dévouements
qui ont poussé ses proches à demander
que lui soit remise cette distinction
créé en 1963 par Charles de Gaulle ainsi
se referme donc cette édition à demain
pour un nouveau journal lundi soir vous
avez rendez-vous avec Antony re pour le
78 sport bonne
soirée